à peine arrivé notre présence est
signalée alerté le concepteur duval
s'empresse de venir protéger l'identité
de sa création
lui même préfère rester anonyme allant
jusqu'à se cacher dans les souliers du
roi du carnaval
alors pour en savoir plus nous avons
tout tenté
à commencer par respect youn et les
conversations des ouvriers présents
moi c'est écouter un autre cadet parce
que mon combat en tout cas pas les ils
veulent nous faire avaler mais pas du
valais manuela maleeva nous l'avons pas
laisser traîner avec mobinil beauté ça
me fait mal pourquoi pas aller vous
pourrez dire et là il ne la ratons à une
balle qui vous mais sans grand succès
alors pourquoi pas tout simplement poser
la question directement à valdoie liu
wang a dévoilé au sens que biais d'un
pagne dévoilé khimki qui sert qu'a
représenté donc ça c'est bien la loi
réfléchir à ce que vous sortez de
l'endroit on est en train de faire le
valais vous musical un manteau mais
pourquoi donc tant de méfiance
l'an dernier l'identité de vannes avait
été révélée avant l'heure ce qui avait
passablement agacé sa majesté nous avons
prétexté une interview sur la question
pour tenter de filmer le roi du carnaval
à son insu lors de sa préparation
juste derrière l'interviewer alors là
c'était pas sérieux quelqu'un venu dont
j'ai vu la personne en question mais
j'avais pas assez de preuves ou du cycle
une femme est une femme une des
maîtresses d'une des maîtresses de
valpré support je suis pas inscrite et
ça et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
me suis fait avoir mais cette année
yopougon i
chlordécone réforme des retraites
coronavirus élections municipales
inégalités sociales les mois écoulés
n'ont pas manqué d'actualité sont
comptés que valve nous à ces dernières
années habitué aux thèmes multiples
alors pourquoi pas aussi un clin d'oeil
à l'obéissance à la loi
un syndicaliste de la police au
featuring imposé par une star du rap ou
encore aux indices pression actuelle sur
la vie privée de ce même chanteur